you're paying more for everything a
dozen eggs and a pack of bacon now cost
almost 30 percent more than last year
beef pork chop sugar all up double
digits so what's the buying
administration's solution
spend more
prices have gone up
and
families and individuals
are dealing with the realities of of
the that bread costs more the gas cost
more that is a heavy weight to carry
bill back better
is not going to cost
anything we're paying for it
yeah what about rising gas prices well
obviously go green
the rise in gas prices over the long
term makes it an even stronger case for
doubling down our investment and our
focus on clean energy
all right joey i want to come to you
first because you know obviously
inflation you know you can have off
balance with supply and demand that can
be a cause but also when a government
prints and borrows and spends money that
the money supply has increased by 36
percent in the last
uh two years alone that too will cause
inflation does it make sense that we
spend more money when we're seeing
inflation rise right now
i think the person we need to ask that
question to is joe mentioned because it
may all fall on his shoulders and the
people of west virginia probably don't
want to see that happen
i can tell you that you know i come from
a pretty small town
and it's not easy it's not easy when the
money you have in the bank is worth less
from one day to the other and you don't
have a lot there to begin with and i
think that's the part that people kind
of gloss over
in i'm learning this myself i'm not an
economist i mean last time i had a job
with math involved i lost my legs so i
kind of keep it where i where i know
what to do but what i'll tell you is
people sitting at home that only have
maybe a thousand dollars in the bank or
a couple thousand dollars in the bank
and every single day that couple
thousand dollars stretches a little less
it's worth less that's concerning and
when your vice president united states
doesn't seem to be able to answer a
simple question on it without looking
incredibly uncomfortable it's not so
much how did we get here the american
people sitting at home or asking it's
what are you going to do about it how
are you going to fix it and it looks
like this administration doesn't have
any answers for them and that's scary
and when people get scared then they
pull their money back and they're worth
less money back and then everything
starts to crumble so that's what we're
worried about are we sitting on a
housing bubble they're building a
thousand homes between my house and the
interstate things like that are worrying
people and they deserve answers and if
it's possible action and i don't know
that a three trillion dollar plan or
four trillion dollar plan or one and a
half trillion dollar plan is the answer
they're looking for
but it's interesting troy because they
say that the answer to everything is
government but when you have rising uh
prices they have no solutions for it but
emily i want to go to you because i
think it's fascinating too they're like
well yes there's a rise in energy prices
and everyone's starting to travel for
the holiday season uh the answer to that
is green energy you know not drilling
more in america or not opening up more
pipelines but green energy why don't we
just produce more american energy
for you know oil and gas
i mean the problem is regardless how you
feel politically numbers facts and data
do not lie and that's something that i
think this administration has yet to
learn to your point sean you don't
invest in green energy without shoring
up existing energy that is the backbone
of our current economics first to joy's
point as well about the the value
plummeting of the dollar every american
feels at their kitchen table when the
dollar is strong when inflation is low
average hourly wages have plummeted 1.2
percent in the last year 1.6 if you take
into account the decrease in work week
hours under the prior administration
contrast that poverty was its lowest
since 1959 and for the first time in a
long time americans with low education
uh with with middle and and low income
were finally sharing in the country's
growth we achieved more in a median rate
and a median income we achieved more
growth 50 percent more in one year than
we did in all eight years of the obama
administration and that is what the
american people feel they see when heat
bills increase by 700 they see when gas
prices increase 300 percent so this
administration needs to understand how
to realize reality and the reality
facing average americans before they get
into their esoterics and promise us a
green future
that's right so aisha uh kamala harris
was actually asked about rising prices
let's take a listen to what she had to
say when asked
will this be the most expensive
christmas in history after the most
expensive thanksgiving in history as
i said earlier fully appreciate
the significance of things costing more
it's a big deal
it's a big deal
yeah so
it is a big deal but again there's no
solutions for it but i want to get i
want to get your take on this because
it's interesting that that you have
democrats in the house not wanting to
vote moderate democrats not wanting to
vote on uh this massive legislation
they're actually waiting for the cbo to
come out and score this bill because
they're concerned about inflation which
means they must not really trust the
bite administration when they say this
is going to cost nothing
i love the fact that joey knows senator
manchin and is following him very very
closely because that's the guy that
everyone's been paying attention to and
i'm surprised that joe manchin wasn't
like the halloween costume of the year
because he is a man of the hour but
you're right there he's not the only one
him and kirsten cinema they're not the
only ones there are a bunch of house
moderates that are dragging their heels
i mean ask yourselves
why did they not vote for both of these
bills a bipartisan infrastructure bill
along with bill back better at the same
time why are they dragging their feet
it's because they don't trust the white
house numbers they don't trust what the
white house is putting out they want to
wait for the congressional budget office
to come out with their analysis because
that is i mean the gold standard and i
just want to bring up there are other
analysis out there including the penn
wharton budget model which is
nonpartisan by the way and it found that
the nearly two trillion dollar plan that
the white house is putting out over 10
years actually closer to 4 trillion so
there are doubts about what the cbo
score is going to come back as but again
don't underestimate the fact that house
speaker nancy pelosi had to decouple
these two bills which was really the
only reason it was taking so long to get
anything done was because they had
coupled these two bills the fact that
she decoupled these two bills i mean
really speaks for itself is because
moderates are pretty much holding this
bill hostage now until they get that cbo
score so we'll have to see how they
respond once it comes out sean may i
just make a final point here really
quickly just a reminder which is
something that the democrat party
doesn't doesn't realize every dollar of
the government's is ours it is our tax
dollars that pay for this so when the vp
comes out and says oh this won't cost
anything costs are absorbed somewhere
they are never extinguished fully and it
is our tax dollars that pays for this
whole thing and that is the issue with
the democrat party
yeah yeah you guys just watched this the
decoupling now means that the socialist
left-wing of the party has lost leverage
to get this done so but good discussion
guys